this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists who do you talk to when
you're feeling sad
depressed anxious or overwhelmed who do
you talk to when you're grieving
that's we're going to discuss today
we're here with lori gottlieb she's the
author of
maybe you should talk to someone also
her new podcast is called
dear therapist i believe you're in
season two right now
we are we are yeah congratulations yeah
awesome podcast
doing a great job it's yeah i really
like it you know what we have so much to
talk about today
and uh ryan often refers to his mommy
and daddy issues as he calls them
i think we'll get to some of those on
the maximal episode and also
i have this weird aversion to
achievement and maybe i think you could
help me unpack that a little bit
so you'll help both of us maybe deal
with our problems on the maximal but
during this minimal today
we want to talk about therapy we want to
talk about mental health this is a
listener
driven show so i thought we would dive
right in to our
questions we have a question here from
instagram jyn has a question for us
when is the appropriate time to talk to
a therapist
is there someone we should talk to
before we seek professional help
hmm so you know i think about this as
well because i talk
i often talk to ryan as though he's my
therapist i have a strange sort of
aversion to therapy and i realize that
might be a blind spot for me
so maybe i'm definitely not the right
person to be answering this question
but ryan has helped me sort through a
lot of my
a lot of understanding with respect to
issues that i have that come up in my
life now we've known each other for a
really long time we were fat little
fifth graders when
we met and so he has an understanding of
me and also my preferences my
behaviors my well really my my um
my beliefs my values as well and so
he's often someone i talk to first in
fact i've talked to several therapists
in the past
and quite often ryan helps me unpack
things better than
those people have helped me but i think
that might say something about me
yeah i was going to say that's really
interesting because usually it's the
opposite so so many of us
think um you know let me go to my
friends with this problem and the
problem with doing that and i'm not
saying don't talk to your friends you
should talk to your friends
but what friends offer us is something
called idiot compassion usually
and and and so what they do is they back
up your story so you're like
this thing happened with my boss or with
my partner with my mom or my child or
whatever it is
and we're like yeah you know you're
right they're wrong and
how could they do that that's terrible
we always take our friends
side because we think that we're
supporting them but actually that's not
very helpful because if you listen to
your friends over time there's often
some
pattern right that like like well why do
guys keep breaking up with you will they
keep breaking up with you maybe if you
stop going through their phones or you
stop like you know texting them at all
hours whatever it is right
we don't say that to them it's and and
and so what people really need to see
it's kind of like if a fight breaks out
in every bar you're going to
maybe it's you we don't say that to our
friends because we feel like they don't
they don't want to hear that when you go
to a therapist you get wise compassion
wise compassion is when we hold up a
mirror to you and we help you to see
something about yourself
that maybe you haven't been willing or
able to see
and so what are your patterns what are
these blind spots
what are the ways in which you
self-sabotage what are the ways in which
you are playing a role in what's not
working in your life
let's talk about self-sabotage what does
that mean and
how does it manifest in different people
it's like
the difference between what we say we
want and what we
do so we say we want something and then
we do
the very thing that will guarantee that
we don't get that something
that's self-sabotage okay okay so
i'm trying to think of some examples
here so so some easy examples
would be with respect to diet or
exercise maybe i want to go to the gym
every single day but
instead i'm sitting on the couch eating
potato chips sort of thing
right right and there are other ways
like you know i
i don't like the job that i'm in but oh
yeah i was offered my dream job but oh
the commute is so far so i'm not going
to take it
right like what is that resistance
what's happening and part of it is that
changing our ways is so hard so we think
that change
even positive change is going to be good
for us so you say you know this is why
new year's resolutions fail all the time
right because you're making a change
that you think is positive
and then you say well why can't i make
this change if i know that it's good for
me
um and and that's because maybe you
should talk to someone there's a chapter
called how humans
change and it's about the stages of
change and it's not like nike where it's
like just do it
right you know we think that's what is
it make up my mind i'm gonna make this
change and i'm gonna do it
it doesn't generally last usually there
are a lot of stages before there's
pre-contemplation
where you don't even know that you're
thinking about making a change
there's contemplation where now it's
conscious and you know okay
i want to make this change but i'm not
ready yet and then there's preparation
where you start preparing to make the
change
and then action is the is the just do it
phase where you're actually going to do
it
but the most important phase of change
is maintenance
so people think once you've made the
change that's the change no maintenance
is how do you maintain
the change and what people don't know
about maintenance is that you are going
to slip back that's built into
maintenance so most people think
oh like take new year's resolutions um
you know i'm going to
exercise more and then you go through
this phase where you're like oh i didn't
exercise today see i failed at this
forget it i'm just going to sit on the
couch for the rest of the year
right that's what people do but no you
just okay that was that day and then you
get back on track
the next day and as you keep getting
back on track you're going to slip back
less until the new thing becomes a habit
and a new way of life for you
people do this with change with like
they won't leave a relationship that
they know they need to leave
or they they won't um you know do
something in their job to
move ahead where they know they really
want to move ahead and be promoted but
they don't do those things
because they they they haven't gone
through all of these stages of change
and it's it's generally not going to
work if you haven't done that
interesting so i mean just going back to
another example if there's a woman who
is like with an abusive partner
what what are the what are the reasons
for her being so scared
to to leave that relationship well so so
change
involves loss and what you're losing is
the familiar
even if the familiar is miserable like
this woman who's with the abusive
partner
um but it's familiar at least she knows
it and so the thing about change is that
it leads to
uncertainty and humans don't do well
with uncertainty
we don't like that we like to have
control we like to know what's happening
it's kind of like with change she can
leave that guy but then she's going to
be plopped into this
foreign land where she doesn't know the
culture the mores the language the
directions
and that's really scary at least with
this guy and this is
terrible reason to stay with someone but
in her mind probably at least with this
guy
she knows what she's going to get yeah
she knows what to expect she knows what
to expect and so if
change really forces you to push
yourself out of your comfort zone
and and that's why i think for someone
like that going you know going back to
your question about you know
what is it what is the good of going to
a therapist um
i think a therapist can really help you
to see what is holding you back here
because you can talk about it forever
with your friends probably nothing's
going to change
something internal has to shift and if
you want to get to that place a
therapist can help you get there faster
yeah i know for me i always talk about
having a therapist is like
it's a tool in my toolbox that i need to
go to every once in a while i do talk to
josh a lot about my problems and
he's very helpful but sometimes i need
like this outside opinion
to kind of help me get a different
perspective and that's what i feel like
i have a therapist
who i see when i'm just having some
troubles getting over certain certain
things certain thoughts
and what he does for me is he almost
like gives me different lenses
to look at the situation and then i get
to choose which lens i look at it
through and it helps me to process
these feelings a little bit more i love
the mirror reference too because that's
the other thing too like we
a therapist can help you take a little
bit more responsibility than maybe
you're not taking right so first of all
i think going to a therapist is like
getting a really good second opinion on
your life
from someone who's not already in your
life and and people don't really think
of it that way
so i think that that's that's really
important and this thing about the
lenses right so
a lot of times people come to therapy
and they want something to change
but usually what they want to change is
someone else or something else
so it's like change this problematic
person
in my life i'm here because they're the
problem
and by the way you know we have this
saying in therapy before diagnosing
someone with depression make sure they
aren't surrounded by [ __ ] so
you know i'm not saying there aren't
difficult people out there
[Music]
you know there are difficult people but
then the question is okay why are you in
relationship with this difficult person
or what is your role in making things
even more
difficult how do you respond to this
person how do you do the dance with this
person
so that you keep revisiting the same
argument the same conflict the same
tension
whatever it is so it helps you to
understand more about
your part so that you have agency i
think the great thing about therapy is
it gives you agency a lot of people come
in and they say you know i'm
i'm helpless because of all these all
these people out there all these
circumstances and it's like
you have a role in your own life too and
this is how you can have agency in your
own life i love it it's almost like some
people uh maybe they don't even know
what level to take responsibility
so i think a therapist can help someone
get to that that appropriate level
um yeah i i think a therapist everyone
should have a therapist
in their phone because it is it's a tool
that you can have in your toolbox that
yeah that can really help you get
through things so to answer like john's
question head-on i would say
jen if you find yourself getting stuck
if you find yourself
uh doing the same thing over and over
again and uh
you're it's hard to break a pattern like
this is where like yeah maybe you want
to go to an outside source
to help you make the changes you want to
make in your life i would say one more
thing in answer to her question which is
and maybe you should talk to someone my
own therapist at one point when i was
feeling stuck
said you know you remind me of this
cartoon and it's of a prisoner
shaking the bars desperately trying to
get out but on the right and the left
it's open
no bars and so why don't we walk around
the bars if it's open right she can walk
out of that relationship but why don't
we because with freedom
comes responsibility and if we walk
around the bars then we are responsible
for our own lives
and that can be incredibly scary yeah
yeah when we're talking about
who therapy is appropriate for we also
have to keep in mind
that not everyone can afford therapy as
well in fact i know podcast sean is
going through this as well so
usually we have people call and leave
voicemails or they
obviously text or tweet questions to us
but i figured we'd let podcast shawn
ask a question today on microphone since
he's he's going through
something personally podcast sean yeah i
appreciate that
um what do we do when cost is an
impediment to mental health care
several members of my family could
certainly benefit from the care and
guidance of a licensed therapist
but our health insurance won't cover it
we're right in the sweet spot of income
where we don't qualify for public
assistance
and licensed therapists in our area
hovering around five hundred dollars an
hour
so he's saying that we're paying him too
much ryan
which which is five hundred dollars an
hour out of pocket for us which is a
significant impact on our monthly budget
we're not paying him that much
another family member of ours was in a
similar situate
situation rather which likely
contributed to his suicide when he
couldn't afford appropriate care
um wow so that is a real issue that has
been an issue
i think you know always and that's
because we don't treat
mental health the way that we treat
physical health so
physical health you get insurance um
you know people don't say oh you broke
an arm well sorry
you know you're just gonna have to sit
there with the broken arm right you go
to the emergency room there are ways to
handle that
um you know and i think that what a lot
of people don't know though is that
there
are free like low fee or no fee clinics
in most major cities and one thing that
happened during covid was people said i
don't even have to be in that city
right so now because of because
everybody started doing things online
and people are continuing to do that
if your city doesn't have a clinic so
we're here in l.a there are tons of them
um and and it's based on your income you
show them your
all of your information and you pay you
know some of them are no fees some of
them are like five dollars a session
some of them are like 20
a session depending on your income um so
people don't know that they have access
to those
so that's really important to google
those in your city
um and and i would say the other thing
to do is to
help family members sometimes family
members you know don't know how to go
about this
so to help them and give them the
references and help them to make those
phone calls mm-hmm
that's beautiful yeah yeah i was
thinking earlier when you talked about
how
we're constantly trying to change other
people and i mean this has been going on
for millennia
obviously right and and so my problem is
always that someone else is
it's easier for me to offload the blame
onto someone else right
you did this to me you're responsible
for my own
for my discontent well of course no one
has the power to make me
upset angry sad whatever it's always
ultimately on me but it's very easy to
have these externalities and the reason
we started the whole minimalist
is is well we pursue happiness through
externalities usually through things and
in our culture right
and of course when that doesn't work
then we often turn to other things that
also make us discontent whether it's
addiction you know alcohol abuse etc and
with the trying to change other people
i'm sure that you've seen quite a few
people
especially in like couples therapy for
example where it's
hey let's go to couples therapy so i can
help you
change let's talk about the downsides of
trying to change other people
i see a lot of couples in my practice
and
one of the things that i do before they
even come in is i have them
think about how they want to make the
relationship better what they
individually can do so before they even
come in
the focus isn't how are you going to
change something about the other person
it's
what is your goal for yourself in terms
of how you think
you can make this relationship better
and i think that's a great
orientation to start with because
already it's
i'm going to do everything i can in my
power to be the best person i can be in
this relationship and whatever they do
they do
my partner and i think that it makes
each person take responsibility for
their role and they see the other person
taking responsibility
and that makes them motivated to change
too yeah it's such a hard first step but
like
when it comes to any tumultuous
relationship uh
i know i was guilty of having a
tumultuous relationship where i'm like
well
i'm not going to start trying until they
start trying and that's
yeah no no when attitude right right
well actually because it's it's really
the relationship that you're working on
it's not you're not working on the other
person
you're working on the relationship and
you're working on who are you in the
relationship
yeah um you know on our podcast on the
dear therapist podcast
we have couples on sometimes and it's
really fun we had
because i think you you move them so
much more quickly when you have both of
them together and i find this in my
practice too
so um in season two we have a a mother
and
her daughter on her adult daughter and
they have a lot of
long-standing issues and it's really
great to
work with them together because we you
can hear us on the podcast getting each
of them to take responsibility for their
own role
and to make changes um and and you can
see it happen
in real time on the podcast oh man i
want to
call in with my mother and get some help
well she had made the comment to me one
time she was like um
you know for us to work out every all of
our issues she was like we need to sit
down in a room with a therapist
and work out all our issues and like
we've never we've never done anything we
both have really gone out of our way to
like
make the relationship better why didn't
you take her up on that
uh because she's in ohio and i'm in
montana and it's you know it's a really
easy excuse to
be like well you know we're not together
in the same city but certainly there's a
way to do it there is a way to do it
yeah online
on yeah we have the if your mother is
watching this
i'm holding you accountable right now i
love it yeah yeah i really like it
because uh
this has kind of inspired me to try
harder because
i mean the fact is is like i didn't do
it because it wasn't something i felt
like
i needed to do it's not something that i
desired as much as she desired however
if i really want to improve the
relationship between us
i would recognize her desires and i
would i would do it
you know do something try to try
something to to fulfill whatever she's
asking of me so
yes thank you for thank you for
inspiring this to me i will look into it
maybe got a recommendation to someone i
can uh
i can you know put on a skype call or
something that would be good i
i like that the fact that there is there
are affordable options
essentially for everyone because that's
a thing that we don't think about i know
sean was going through that and trying
to figure out okay there's someone in my
family
who could use some help but also
spending 500
an hour is untenable right and so
realizing that wait wait a minute if i
do need help there are people
who are distant enough from the
relationship or from me or from my
situation
who can point me in the right direction
yeah we have a question here from
nancy in rock island illinois it may
help to have a saying or two to motivate
you or call you when things aren't like
you'd like them to be
a sort of attitude of gratitude uh quote
that's helped me on this mobilization is
grant me the serenity to accept the
things i cannot change
courage to change the things i can and
wisdom to know the difference
my questions what other spots or sayings
have helped you so lori if i were to
rephrase nancy's question
here maybe we just say what mantras
self-talk
meditations etc have helped you
keep focused centered and positive when
addressing some of life's challenges so
what are your thoughts on you know
positive self-talk in general
well you know i i did a ted talk about
how we all have these stories that we
carry around
about ourselves in our heads you know
they might be like i'm unlovable or i
can't trust anyone or nothing will ever
work out for me
and i think that when we don't realize
that those are operating in the
background they affect
every choice decision everything that we
do
basically every interaction we have
during our daily lives
and so i think that we need to kind of
change
how we're talking to ourselves so some
people use these affirmations to do that
um other people really sort of you know
kind of change the radio station when
that like you know horrible radio
station is playing with these these
messages that just
aren't true um and you know i when i
give talks often i will be
you know up on the stage and i'll say
you know show of hands who's the person
that you talk to
most in the course of your life is it
your partner your parents your
sibling you know whatever it is and you
get lots of hands for those
but the person that we talk to most in
the course of our lives is ourselves
yes and what we say to ourselves is not
always kind or true or useful
and so i think that when you start to
notice that you're speaking to yourself
in a way
that is not kind or true or useful
that's a time it doesn't have to be an
affirmation it could just be
a wait a minute this is just not helpful
in any way it's not true
it's not kind it's not useful um
i find that i had a client most people
don't realize that they are so
self-critical
and so i had a client who was like that
and i said i want you to go home
and i want you to write down listen for
that voice in your head and write down
everything
that you hear and come back next week
and we'll talk about it
and she was very skeptical but she came
back the next week she had done the
assignment she gets out her phone and
starts reading this and she starts
crying and she says i can't even read
this to you
because i am such a bully to myself i
had no idea
and they were things like she was typing
an email and she she had made a typo and
she said to herself you're so stupid
or she like caught her reflection in a
mirror and she said god you look
terrible
you know just these ways that you would
never talk to a friend that way because
you wouldn't
actually think that if your friend made
a typo or looked however you looked that
day
you would not think that of your friend
or you wouldn't spend any more time with
that friend if they were constantly
criticizing you
the way that you criticize you one of my
favorite lyrics is from a
singer-songwriter named matt nathanson
he said i would kill anyone who treats
you as bad as you do
yes yes so we have to be good friends to
ourselves we have to have a good
relationship with
ourselves yeah it's
easier said than done but uh but yeah
it's it
because i find myself with the negative
self-talk and
i do catch myself and i'm like okay man
like this is not helpful this is just
you know producing more anxiety um i can
hold space for it and say okay like
there's something going on
but instead of feeling bad it's like hey
nicodemus like be better
like that's really what it comes down to
and that's you know it's just like a
little affirmation that
just helps me rephrase it and i don't
even know if that's the right way to
approach it but it does help me to
interrupt
those those negative thoughts but well i
think i think that what people need in
those moments is self-compassion
oh yeah and and people think that if
they have self-compassion that somehow
that they're being weak you know it's
like oh that's indulgent
um as opposed to and people think the
way that i'm gonna get ahead the way
that i'm gonna succeed in life is if i
self-flagellate
if i'm like work harder be better you
know like that kind of thing
no um self-compassion actually takes
away the shame
so when you self-flagellate you're sort
of bathed in shame for whatever the
thing is that you perceive
that you didn't do well enough and when
you get rid of the shame
there's room for oh i'm human um you
know this is something that i would do
differently next time
and now i'm gonna go do things
differently it opens things up for you
instead of instead of like keeping you
in the same place
so maybe like a path towards self-love
is
self-compassion because one time i was
late
calling a friend and i just felt so
guilty like you know time flew by
and i was like i'm so sorry man then i'm
just like going on and on and on he's
like hey man do you want to make it up
to me i'm like yes
what can i do to make it up to you he
was like be really kind to yourself
right now
i love that i love that that's a good
friend and it was and it was like an
instant like
weight off my shoulders and i'm so glad
he said that because yeah it reminds me
that it's
much better to show myself compassion
than like suck it up nicodemus
yeah yeah we can be so unkind to
ourselves
and and part of that is it's not really
our voice we're not born that way
you know we're not born sort of you know
criticizing ourselves
it's some voice that we heard somewhere
else that got internalized
and i think for a lot of people what
happens is you know a lot of the work of
therapy
is helping people to let go of the hope
for having had a better childhood
oh yeah and what i mean by that is that
if you don't
grieve whatever you whatever loss you
feel like you missed out on in childhood
or whatever however you were
disappointed in childhood
and i'm not saying everybody was but
there's no such thing as a perfect
parent
and we don't blame parents in therapy
we're not there to blame parents at all
because parents are human too and they
did their best
there's there's not a parent that i have
ever met no matter how
limited they might have been who didn't
truly
want the best for their child even if
they went about it in a way
that was incredibly unfortunate that's
pretty powerful
yeah it's interesting i had this
realization just a few years ago
because i would always tell myself my
childhood should have been this way my
parents should have done this they
should have done that
and you know i got all this resentment
and you know it just builds and built
and then i had this realization of like
wait
like ryan you're almost 40 years old man
and you don't have it figured out your
parents had you at 20.
like why would i expect them to have it
figured out at 20 if i don't have it
figured out a 40 and certainly now
they're
in their 60s yeah and it's the same
thing like they don't they're just
trying to
live their lives the same way and it
really helped me put in perspective
that they did what they could well it's
both
and so when we get older we can see our
parents
as as humans as opposed to the people
who we wish had
done something differently for us and we
have a lot of compassion for that
because we're adults
and we see oh wow we're fallible too we
make mistakes too
um and so i say both and because and we
can grieve what we didn't get so it's
not just like
forgive them and i have you know i talk
and maybe you should talk to someone a
lot about forced forgiveness that people
think
you're supposed to forgive people and
that will set you free
now for some people that is helpful but
for others it feels like wait a minute i
don't
actually forgive this i can have
compassion for my mother my father for
this person
i can have compassion for them that i
couldn't have when i was younger
but that doesn't necessarily mean that i
forgive them and somehow
you know that can be a lot more freeing
for a lot of people
that's huge that i mean that just helped
me in the sense that
like my stepfather was very abusive and
we i've talked before on the podcast
about forgiving him and i ca
it's like intellectually i'm like hey i
forgive you
but emotionally like it's hard for me to
not well right it's hard for me to let
it go but
but what i can work on is showing him
more compassion and start there before i
you know maybe that'll help me work
towards forgiveness
and you don't have to get to forgiveness
that that's the whole point
is that the thing about the thing about
forced forgiveness is that it's forced
and so it's it's it's a good thing as we
grow up and a sign of maturity where we
can have compassion for other people
and we can understand where they came
from and maybe why
they were doing what they were doing but
that doesn't mean you forgive the fact
that he abused you
yeah right and so you can hold both at
the same time
and that's that's really what we do a
lot in therapy right
is holding both so it's not like the
parents are we're there to slam the
parents we're not
but we're also there to say yes you you
were exposed to this thing you
experienced this thing and that was
incredibly difficult yeah see this whole
podcast was just a ruse to get you in
here and give me a
therapy therapy session but we'll touch
more on that on the maximum nancy i'm
gonna send you a copy of
maybe you should talk to someone and i
also want to send you a copy of our new
book it's called love people use
things in fact i was told by the
publisher yesterday
i'm supposed to say this to announce it
from the rooftops
it is now a new york times best-selling
book
but i have an aversion to even talking
about this and so maybe you can help me
unpack that a little bit when we get
onto the maximum episode because
to me it feels a little bit egoic and
not that that's a bad
thing but it's not the driver for doing
what we
do and so i don't know maybe i have a
slight allergy
to the whole thing maybe you can unpack
that
okay so having just had a book you know
come out so with maybe you should talk
to someone i'm gonna say this
loud and proud which goes against every
cultural mandate
um the book was on the new york times
bestseller list for a year it sold over
a million copies so far
um and i am really proud of that okay
and i think that we have this thing
where we're not allowed to be
proud of something that's very
meaningful to us my book was incredibly
meaningful to me your book i know
you wrote for the same reasons it was
incredibly meaningful and it's touching
so many people
and so why not be proud of that yeah
well
okay let's get into it in the moment
yeah we will because there's so much to
talk about yeah why not be proud of is a
great question
by the way nancy i'd also love to give
you a couple tickets to
our live event we're coming to illinois
we'll be in chicago which is
not too far from you we're doing 20
cities this fall and winter it's called
the love people
use things tour we're going to give a
live minimalism talk
i'm going to do a reading from the book
we're also going to do a live
version of the minimalist podcast and
answer a bunch of your questions on the
road
20 cities u.s and canada you can find
all the details
over the minimalists.com tour but
podcast sean if you could please
reach out to nancy and give her a couple
tickets we'd love to see you there ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it is time for our lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654
yes indeed now lori during the lightning
round this is where we do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes what podcast sean does
so our good friend jessica lynn williams
can copy and share them on
social media and you listening at home
can copy and share these pithy sayings
on
social media as well but really what we
do is we monitor on a bit until we find
something that is
somewhat pithy that sean will edit down
and make it look beautiful
we have a question here from jackie why
does there seem to be a
stigma against mental health in older
generations and more specifically
how can we get our parents to talk about
their feelings and vulnerabilities
so lord well i'll give you a pity answer
from me and maybe we can unpack it
together here
to love someone is to see them for who
they are without trying to change them
i think quite often we think of love as
conditional hey if you do these seven
different things then i will love you
right or hey if i do these seven
different things then i can force ryan
to
love me as well as though it's a grocery
list or
a top seven list on reddit or something
right
but that's a misunderstanding of love
in a way now that doesn't answer this
question directly here
but i think quite often what what we try
to do is say
well you're supposed to share your
feelings here's what you need
yes yeah with me and i want to be
careful
there but i'd love to hear your thoughts
well i think that
different people communicate in
different ways and so
um you know your parents might
communicate their love
maybe not through what they say but
through what they do
some people communicate their love
through their body language as opposed
to through their words
so um you know so i think that the what
you have to be you have to honor the
different ways that people communicate
um yeah i love that um i think in terms
of getting people to
go to therapy right um i think that if
you see someone struggling
the way to approach them is to say it
breaks my heart to see you struggle so
much
i care so much about you i've been to
someone
um maybe it would help to go talk to
someone right so it doesn't make it like
you have a problem or you're always
yelling or you're depressed or you're
anxious so you need to go to therapy
it's more like i want you to i want you
to struggle less like i see you're
having a hard time and it breaks my
heart because i care so much about you
yes yeah yeah come at it from a loving
compassionate point of view rather than
uh
here's what you should do i'm not
talking to you until you go see a
therapist
well i think the stigma thing too is is
a big thing
you know because i think you know it's
like it's like we have this higher
this sorry we have this hierarchy of
pain um
so it's like it's like um you know well
i'm a little bit sad but i'm not having
an all-out
breakdown so i'm not going to go see a
therapist
you know maybe i'm anxious or i can't
sleep or i'm having these relational
difficulties
but i have a roof over my head and food
on the table so it's not
that bad compared to whatever we don't
do this with physical health right
we don't say well yeah i broke my arm
but i don't have stage four cancer
so i'm not going to go to the doctor or
it's like i have a little heart pain
but not you know i have like i'm having
palpitations but like i'm not on the
floor with a heart attack so i'm not
going to go to the cardiologist
people don't come to therapy until
they're having the equivalent of an
emotional heart attack
so often so it's like you are now it's
like going to the er
why are people waiting so long the
problem with waiting so long is not only
did you suffer unnecessarily for so
long for months sometimes years but
also it's harder to treat at that point
because it's like if you never went to
the doctor and then all of a sudden you
come in and you're really sick
so come in when you want to talk to
someone it doesn't have to be a crisis
you know it was tony soprano and i think
the new york times wrote an article
about how he made it okay
to go see a therapist and i remember
watching that show back in my corporate
days
and you know you know every show pretty
much began with them like talking to his
therapist
and i just remember thinking like oh man
that is so cool that like
he goes and he just like unloads on
someone once a week
and so i started to do that and yeah it
really does make a difference so
um getting ahead of it before you have
this like this this
what did you call it a mental heart
attack emotional emotional heart attack
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i totally yeah i i yeah i
think that's a great great way to look
at it so i gotta really pick the answer
here it's uh
to accept is to love to expect is to
unlove
so accepting your your family your
friends
you know for who they are that's really
uh how you're going to
help that relationship flourish but yeah
throwing these expectations on them
it's probably going to do the opposite
of what you wanted to do it's
interesting it makes me think about
um your podcast you did uh jeff's
critical parents i think as well yes
yes and what was so the biggest takeaway
that i got from that podcast was you
helped him learn
like hey i like it's it's easy to
understand why
you think your parents should be the
teacher and you should be the student
and they should take care of you but
unfortunately the way life goes
sometimes the
the child has to be the teacher and
that's okay
but like taking on that role also might
help uh you know jackie here look at
at her situation with a different
perspective maybe you got to be the
teacher in this situation that's okay
yeah so on the geotherapist podcast one
of the we do a session with somebody
every week and this was with jeff and he
had these very critical
parents and and at the end of it we give
him a homework assignment that he has to
try out and
report back to us on and we ask him to
teach his parents
about being sensitive and making that be
kind of like a superpower right and and
teaching them about
the impact of that they're extremely
critical and what happens when
they say those things to him and and um
what's interesting is in season two that
we just started
we have follow-ups with the people from
season one so we always get a week
follow-up in
every episode but this is a year
follow-up and we just got jeff's oh wow
and i'm not going to give it away
because it's so good but i will just say
this
you remember in the episode his father
reacted very well to
the homework the mother did not react as
well a year later
you guys are gonna love the update i
can't wait to hear it wow oh that's
awesome
we got a bunch more to talk about but
first here are some voicemail comments
and insights from our listeners check
them out
hi my name is lisa and i'm calling from
maryland
i really just wanted to give a comment i
have listened to your podcast
for about a year and have enjoyed many
of them thank you
and i also just wanted to make a comment
in reference to
family friends and gifts
my granddaughter will be four in august
and
my gen y daughter is a budding
minimalist
and as a result of that is trying to
reduce the number of gifts coming into
her home so she did an invitation
and indicated that there could be
donations made to the nicu which my
granddaughter
resided in for a brief period of time
after her birth or
give a donation to her college fund we
were discussing
the backlash that she received from
people that she worked with who came up
to her and told her that she was denying
her child
a childhood and a variety of other
rather negative responses
i'm proud of my daughter she's holding
tight and holding fast and will continue
to use this option for my
granddaughter's birthday
but it was interesting to actually see
this firsthand
as opposed to just you know hearing
about it on the podcast hi guys
my name is alicia aiken i'm calling from
byron minnesota
i'm calling because i listened to the
taco i love your podcast but i
was listening to the clothing episode
this weekend and
i have a good really some really good
recommendation to help find women's
clothing that is responsibly made
um there's a blogger that basically she
works as an ephesus
and then this is like her side passion
but if you go to thegarment.ca she's
canadian
so thegarment.ca you can see her
website and blog and also you can find
her on the garment life on instagram
other companies that i personally love
are ace and jig um their stuff
is expensive but really cool and
beautiful fabrics
it's all ethically made and i also
really like bridge and burn
from portland anyways just thought maybe
that would be helpful
all right y'all big thanks to lori
gottlieb check out her book it's called
maybe you should talk to someone and her
podcast dear therapist we have a bunch
more surprise questions for
laurie this thursday on patreon that's
the maximal episode
on the minimalist private podcast it's a
long form podcast
patreon.com the minimalist to find that
there
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life
of the minimalist i know i already gave
away a couple tour
tickets we're going on tour ryan we'll
be in texas and
seattle and los angeles and san
francisco and toronto and vancouver and
columbus and chicago and minneapolis and
new york and boston and dc and orlando
and nashville and atlanta and i'm
missing a few other
cities as well come out and see us
student i'm so looking forward to
getting back on the road it's been three
years since we've been on the road
you know it's a little it's a little uh
a little bit of a bummer because of
kovid that we probably can't do the hug
line
uh but i'm telling you man like that
just that connection with the audience
uh taking the questions and doing the
live podcast
like that that is my favorite part of
this whole gig man in any city where
they let us do a hug line we'll try to
figure this out
right exactly we'll sneak people we'll
do like contraband hugs
hey man you you want them hugs i got
them right over here come backstage for
a hug
oh god we said hugs not drugs
hey man you got any hugs
back in the green room dude i cannot i
can't wait you know it's it's exhausting
being on the road but it's like the most
delightful exhaustion ever yes
it's this joyous i remember kobe bryant
his very last game sadly was against the
utah jazz
and uh he scored 60 points that game
and i've never seen a more tired person
in my life this is back in 2016.
i mean his nose was red like rudolph red
i think he was breathing so
hard but you could just see this pure
joy that was emanating from him
it wasn't excitement it was something
else it was something more than it was
everything yeah and i feel that we're on
the road by the way we're trying to make
all of these all-ages shows most of them
are
there's a few of these i believe it's
like salt lake city there's a state law
that if they
serve alcohol you can't be under 21 and
be there
we're trying to get around that if
possible most of these are all ages
because a lot of people bring
their 16 year old their 17 year old or
quite often their 16 year old brings
the parents to one of these events most
of these are
all ages you can find all the cities all
the ticket information
get your tickets soon these are smaller
venues and a lot of them are already
selling quite a few tickets we just
announced this last week so
there is plenty of time for you to get
it now
because if you wait a month two months
three months
well then you might have to buy tickets
from a scalper or something else so
we don't want that the tickets are
reasonably priced the minimalists.com
tour come here ryan give a talk i'm
going to give a reading we're going to
have a live podcast we're going to
answer your questions
we're gonna have an outstanding night
experience
a night of less for our added value this
week ryan
i thought we listened to this new song
by juvenile manny fresh and mia x it's
called
vaxx that thing up we're actually not
going to listen to that
it's so good because it's so so bad
yes i mean you talk about ruining we're
actually we're not listening to it
they did this commercial psa for
vaccines
and you take a piece i mean it yeah it
sounds weird to call you
back that ass up a piece of art but it
is it's a it's called a piece of art
and and it's iconic it absolutely is an
iconic song and then you ruin it with
the
by creating a some sort of public
service and now backs a thing up he's
like using uh vaccine cards like making
it rain vaccine cars
right oh my god so absurd uh anyway yeah
regardless of how you feel about the
vaccines
it is you you will find that absurd no
matter where
you are on the the spectrum you'll watch
a video like that
yes but the actual added value this week
i've been using this app right i know
you did this
this breathing exercise with jacob a few
weeks ago where you hosted a breathing
class
and um i think it's absurd first off
that i have to have an app on my phone
to remind me to breathe
because it is something i literally do
all day every day even when i'm sleeping
i breathe
dude life is absurd amen to that i use
an app i think it's free
the ad free version might cost a dollar
or something i i don't know this is not
an advertisement it's something i find
value in my doctor actually recommended
it to me
it's called i breathe we'll put a link
to it in the show notes but
anytime throughout the day it can it'll
just pop up a reminder remind you to
breathe but it gives you these breathing
exercises as well so you can do like box
breathing
inhale for five seconds hold for five
seconds exhale for five seconds hold for
five seconds
or they have these other patterns as
well that have been proven
effective for relieving stress and
anxiety and we're talking about a lot of
that on the maximal episode
this week as well so we're just going to
finish this episode with the good old
peter doran
song every little thing that's our theme
song yeah by the way we have a bunch
more surprise questions this week ryan
like
when is mental health just a buzzword
that justifies poor behavior
how do you help someone who is
struggling with anxiety
or depression while maintaining your own
self-care
what is the role of the ego in our
negative feelings
what are some signs that someone is
dependent on their therapist
plus a million more questions for lori
gottlieb
and if you want to hear all that join us
on the minimalist private podcast this
week visit
patreon.com the minimalist to subscribe
and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app by the way there are two tiers over
there who actually get
recordings of all of our live events as
well so if you can't join us in salt
lake city
but you'd like to listen to that event
or see the event you can do that
if you are one of those patreon
supporters you also get access no matter
what tier you're on
to all of our archives hundreds of hours
of minimalism
plus our patreon community interact with
people who are open-minded or
like-minded
over there patreon.com the minimalist
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist if you have a question
comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list it's free
we'll send you any new minimalist
writings that we
publish as well for free if you leave
here today with just one message
let it be this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next
[Music]
every little time you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet
without it